CNN's Don Lemon and two Talking Heads
sidekicks spend nearly a minute and a
half of air time laughing about how
stupid they think half of Americans are
we examine why leftists love humanity
but always seem to hate actual humans
then Liberal Democrat Alan Dershowitz
demolishes House Democrats impeachment
case in a little under three minutes
Liz Warren throws a Hail Mary Hillary
threatens to run again heaven forfend
and drag queen story hour is coming to a
public school near you I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Nolt
show if you ever wondered what the
mainstream media really think of you you
need to look no further than CNN's Don
Lemon I know we we're always knocking
the mainstream media and those left-wing
cable news networks and maybe sometimes
people think it's unfair we're a little
too harsh on them we're not we're not
they hate your guts and CNN's Don Lemon
finally admitted it in a segment it
lasted almost a minute and a half of
them just laughing at Trump supporters
at half of America calling them rubes
calling them idiots they couldn't barely
get the words out because they were
laughing so hard here's just the first
part of it he also knows deep in his
heart that Donald Trump couldn't find
Ukraine in a map if you had the letter U
and a picture of an actual physical
crane that's next to it he knows that
this is you know an administration
defined by ignorance of the world and so
that's partly him playing to their base
and playing to their audience you know
the the the credulous Boomer Rube demo
that backs Donald Trump that wants to
think that the dog Trump's a smart one
in there oh yo yo elitist er all right
now there's the turn right so at the
very beginning Don Lemon cracks up he
cracks up so much as his head he puts
his head down on the desk he just keeps
laughing he keeps laughing and the
person who was speaking there Rick
Wilson is a kind of fake Republican he
was a former Republican strategist who
then in 2016 was so offended by Trump he
worked on that independent candidate
Evan McMullen's campaign he was
colloquially referred to as the Egg
McMuffin campaign and he ran that
obviously didn't go anywhere
and now he spends all of his time
knocking Republicans and conservatives
on CNN so it starts out he makes this
thing he says it's defined by ignorance
Republicans couldn't even find Ukraine
on a map now just a little note here
Republicans know a lot about maps
because for instance we found Wisconsin
on a map in 2016 which is why Trump won
and Hillary lost I digress
he makes the point and then Rick Wilson
is going to go on but Don Lemon is the
one who keeps the joke going Don Lemon
is the one who is encouraging this whole
thing and that's the real problem here
when the commentators come on when the
guests come on these these talk news
shows they often go a little further
than the anchor does right that's kind
of their purpose there as they come on
and they have more personality they
inject more opinion into it and the
anchor is supposed to be there to be the
anchor but on CNN it's exactly the
opposite CNN is the one encouraging this
to break down I mean Don Lemon here is
breaking down and behaving in this
childish way in a play for ratings he's
done this many many times and it does
play for ratings in the same way that a
screaming child gets attention but in
the long run that's not the kind of
attention you want these people are not
going to take you seriously ultimately
that wears pretty thin so he encourages
him and this is where the segment really
really looks bad for CNN and really
looks bad for the left and gives us a
little glimpse into why the left loves
humanity and hates actual humans because
as Don Lemon is laughing Rick Wilson
thinks he's got to play to his audience
now so he puts on this southern accent
to show the dumb
rube idiot Trump voter who can't
identify nothing on a map or nothing
right
so he goes on with this and then the
third guy Waja hot will Hodge it all I
don't know if I'm Brazi his name
correctly he goes on and he he starts
getting in on the joke as well you and
lead us with your geography and your
maps and your spelling given the my bath
you're reading yeah you're reading you
know your geography no in other
countries sipping your latte all those
limes on the mouth
only they Meletis know where Ukraine is
sorry I apologize
it was Rick's fault
I blame Rick now why jihad Ally he's the
only one of these three who actually
realizes this doesn't look good
of all these three knuckleheads on CNN
why jihad Olly is the one who after he
makes this the same joke right it's just
the same joke over and over which is
that Trump supporters are stupid half of
America is stupid he says all I can't
find anything on a map they can't spell
hahahaha it's the same joke but he
realizes gosh it doesn't look good if a
bunch of us from CNN these media elites
are going on condescending and making
fun of half of America doesn't look good
so he says hey Rick started it not me
okay Rick started it I blame Rick and
then he starts to move on as though
they're gonna continue the segment but
they don't even let it go there Don
Lemon finally gets it together at the
end but they keep laughing that was a
good what I needed that okay
the funny thing about it was that it
wasn't actually a good one it was fine
I'm not saying it's it's kind of a basic
joke but it's a joke right it's a it's a
chuckle joke it's not a guffaw joke it's
not a laugh for 90 seconds joke it's a
like sort of oh haha okay moving on they
dragged it out so far the reason that
they're laughing this much is not
because the joke is 90 seconds funny
it's about nine seconds funny the other
81 seconds of laughing is not because
the joke it's funny it's because of how
much these guys in the media despise
conservatives despise half of America
they truly do not like you they do not
like half of their countrymen and
they're mocking them that much because
of it now at first
Waja hot Ally
the the guy on CNN the only guy in CNN
who sort of understood it wasn't a great
look he doubled down so he eat weeded
out quote in response to an article that
said wha jihad alley and Rick Wilson and
Don Lemon trash Trump supporters as
ignorant rubes he said we did not going
to apologize for it either if you're
willing to believe and promote these
absurd and dangerous lies well you
deserve to be mocked for it
he doesn't identify what the absurd and
dangerous lies are but he owns that he
says yes we were mocking and trashing
Trump supporters as ignorant rubes he
got a lot of criticism for that when
that didn't work he did what leftists
always do he played the victim so he
tweeted out right away quote Trump
tweeted our CNN clip from two days ago
friends are now concerned about my
safety
I refuse to be intimidated and bullied
by bad faith actors who cry fake
victimhood whining about a harmless
silly 30-second clip while endorsing
Trump a cruel Vulgarian Hooda bases
everyone ok nothing about what he just
tweeted out was true right first of all
it wasn't a 30-second clip it was a 90
second clip but also who's worried about
your safety that's not what happened at
all that's not what happened at all you
mocked half of America and you thought
it was really really funny and then some
people on Twitter mocked you and you
cried and you whined and you pretended
that you were in physical danger give me
a break
there were some big takeaways here that
the left would do well to consider but I
think really helps the right understand
the way that the life thinks about us
but first I've got to thank our friends
over at two Kovas cowboy boots oh man
to Kovas cowboy weights a new and
wonderful and timely sponsor because I
just launched a podcast with a certain
senator from Texas so you know I had to
get some cowboy boots to Kovas cowboy
boots are hand made with high quality
full grain leather x' by world-class
boot makers they are built to be
comfortable right out of the box this
was the biggest thing for me all right I
haven't worn cowboy boots a whole lot in
my life but I saw that to Kovas catalog
and I just thought they looked
absolutely phenomenal they looked so so
cool so I order this pair I I didn't
have to break them in at all they were
just comfortable right out of the box
and now they have really cool ambitious
leathers so if you want you can get like
ostrich leather I think that one look
incredibly cool but all their leathers
look really really great do what I did
get yourself a pair of two Kovas cowboy
boots today at two Kovas dot-com /
Knowles I love it handmade really really
high-quality and because they're selling
direct to you they can give you prices
that you are not going to get in retail
stores just really a tremendous product
that's to Kovas tec Ovie a s.com /
Knowles canna wles - Kovas dot-com /
Knowles absolutely great boots get
yourself a pair okay big takeaways here
that clip from CNN on Don lemons show
was not from last night that's a two day
old clip so why is it only making the
rounds now it took two days to percolate
because no one watches CNN okay we have
people we have left-wing media
operatives who watch and listen to this
show along with every other daily wire
show along with virtually every other
conservative show on the air every
single day they're watching it all the
time why are they watching it because
the conservative shows matter the
conservative shows are engaging
audiences I mean again not that not to
toot my own horn really the vast
majority of it was Senator Ted Cruz we
launched this podcast verdict with Ted
Cruz the other day it immediately jumped
to the top of the charts number number
one in the country you don't see CNN
podcasts jumping to number one in the
country because nobody's watching CNN
the only people who watch CNN are the
people who were forced to do that in
airports otherwise it's nobody at all it
just doesn't doesn't matter as much for
them so it finally makes the rounds and
it comes out here and they double down
on it I mean that's the part that's so
crazy to me they realize that's not a
good look but they double down they had
the opportunity to apologize and they
didn't and then why jihad alley when
doubling down didn't work he plays the
victim and somehow when you go on
national television and mock half your
countrymen is a bunch of dumb idiots who
are just not even worth talking to
because they can't even spell somehow
that makes you the victim according to
leftist logic because according to
left-wing law
the liberal the progressive the leftist
can never be the oppressor or the tyrant
it's simply not possible they're the
ones trying to go toward progress so
anything they do has to be good and
therefore if they're ever getting
negative feedback for something they say
it has to be that they are the victim I
wish Waja Holly would just maybe
consider for a moment the the
alternative option which is to apologize
and if you don't want to apologize just
I don't know keep your mouth shut for
two days and don't pretend that one guy
on Twitter being mean to you or a number
of guys on Twitter being mean to you is
putting you in physical danger it's just
not true you see actually another
example of this in the media it happened
not specifically with regard to
conservatives but it happened in the
Washington Post right after the death of
Kobe Bryant felicia's on meds is a
national political reporter for the
Washington Post on Sunday hours after
the news breaks that Kobe Bryant and his
daughter and seven other people were
killed tragically in his helicopter
crash she tweets out an article about
Kobe Bryant's rape case it's a headline
Kobe Bryant's disturbing rape case the
DNA evidence the accusers story and the
half confession now this refers to a
case in 2003 Kobe Bryant was accused of
rape he was never convicted of rape
because the woman who accused him
withdrew the charge she refused to
testify Kobe Bryant maintained his
innocence the whole time that he ended
up coming to some sort of settlement and
he apologized to her for what he
continued to maintain was a consensual
sexual encounter obviously not a good
look if you're married anyway but he
still there's there's really no evidence
here that he he raped somebody and this
is this is before his body's even cold
that this this reporter decides in the
the whole life of this man she is going
to go after him for the worst accusation
you could possibly put up against him
this is a theme with the left they've
been doing this for at least 250 years
we're going to be discussing this very
topic on an upcoming episode of my
Prager you show the book club because
there's a whole book about this called
the intellectuals but going all the way
back to the first leftist
ever jean-jacques rousseau that back in
the 18th century all the way up through
Karl Marx up through jean-paul Sartre in
the 20th century all these very
prominent leftists the thing you notice
about them is they judge everybody else
by those people's worst moments the
worst flaws they ever had and yet they
never apply that same standard to
themselves they judge themselves by
their best intentions that's it they can
do no wrong and it's the same on CNN
it's the same in the Washington Post
we'll get to that in a second first got
to thank our friends over at car shield
oh my gosh do I wish that I had car
shield about three months ago this was
before I knew about car shield before
car shield came on the show and I put a
lot of money into my car and my car kept
on breaking down and I did not have the
right coverage that I should have cars
today the thing you got to understand
they are like computers on wheels okay
it's not like the old days when you just
go out with a wrench and and fix up your
car by clicking this doohickey or that I
don't know I've never worked on a car in
my life but that's what my father and my
uncles tell me you used to be able to do
from electronically controlled
transmissions to touchscreen displays to
dozens of sensors all this tech very
very expensive to fix if and when it
breaks core shield has affordable
protection plans that can save you
thousands for a covered repair including
computers GPS electronics and more with
car shield you get to choose your
favorite mechanic or dealership to do
the work and car shield takes care of
the rest I love them I really really
trust these guys right now head on over
to car shield dot-com and enter the code
NOLs that's canna wles
make sure you do that do not wait until
your check engine light goes on you can
also car 800 call 800 car 6000 and
mention the code NOLs when you call and
you will save 10% car shield comm use
the code NOLs save 10% that is car
shield dot-com code Knolls a deductible
may apply the left has been doing this
all the time if you look at the most
prominent leftists in history all the
way back to Rousseau and
marx and sarge and all these guys
they're always terribly cruel to the
people around them always terribly cruel
to acquaintances all while professing
love of humanity they always seem to
think that everyone's got to follow the
rules except them while jihad Ally can
go on CNN and just cruelly mock half of
the country I mean not even in that
funny away it's one joke it's a one note
joke and then the minute anybody goes
and makes a joke about him it's the end
of the world he's in trouble he's
vulnerable he's in physical danger give
me a break
they've always been doing this
journalists like falesha san mez want to
judge people on the worst things you
could possibly accuse them of but they
always judge themselves on their best
intentions that's why they want to
impeach Trump for possibly doing for
possibly thinking about doing what we
know for a fact Joe Biden actually did
it come it comes all right back to this
impeachment trial in this impeachment
the House Democrats are impeaching
Donald Trump for maybe thinking about
engaging in a quid pro quo and
withholding Ukrainian aid in exchange
for a Ukraine investigation of Joe Biden
now that didn't actually happen we know
for a fact it didn't happen we don't
know for a fact Trump was even thinking
it but the whole reason Trump would have
been calling for that investigation in
the first place is because Joe Biden
actually withheld American aid
threatened to withhold American aid if
Ukraine didn't fire the prosecutor who
was investigating his crook son and yet
the left can say perfectly
straight-faced yeah we need to impeach
Trump for that but Joe Biden he's
perfectly fine he might be our
presidential nominee they can say that
they love humanity while not really
hating or well not really loving humans
because really they just love themselves
and conservatives are pretty much the
exact opposite conservatives don't
really like humanity that much I'm very
skeptical of humanity I think that human
nature is broken I think it is flawed we
are never ever going to perfect it
however I love actual humans I really
like individuals I really like talking
to actual humans i if I can I'd like to
help them out it's like a perfect flip
you see this president Trump show this
just the other day President Trump was
driving up he was in his motorcade and
he saw that there were a bunch of
firefighters waiting to salute him so he
pulled on over and got out of his car
and you can see him it's kind of
obviously a little bit hard to hear in
the clip but you can see him he pulls
over I'm sure the Secret Service are
completely freaking out here and he
walks up to them and he just starts
shaking their hands you can hear you can
hear one of the firefighters say like oh
that's so cool
that's so right and he doesn't he gets
back in his car and he leaves now look
Trump is a good retail politician and
it's cool that this clip went viral and
it was good retail politics but you see
this with Trump a lot I'm not sure that
Trump loves humanity all that much but
when he's talking to individual humans
he really seems to like them I mean he
finds a way to like Kim jong-un in North
Korea he finds a way to make friends
with enemies you know people that he
would would scream at and call horrible
names on the campaign trail but then
they kind of get along and they can they
can be friends later on one of the other
very similar moments from Donald Trump
Trump was getting onto marine one he was
getting onto the helicopter and the
Marines hat fell off his head and Trump
just casually leans down picks up the
hat for him this is a minor thing to do
I don't think Trump replanted I only as
part of some grand strategy it's just
the way that people interact one of the
criticisms of Trump's administration is
he's not strategic and abstract and cold
enough it's too much about relationships
I think that's that's the conservative
instinct and frankly I'd much rather
have an instinct in politics of really
liking and engaging with individual
people even if it messes up your
theories then an instinct to love
humanity in theory and and hate them in
real life
now speaking of President Trump the
impeachment trials still underway his
legal team is still making their
arguments we heard from Ken Starr we
heard from his other lawyer Pam Bondi we
heard from a bunch of the Trump team
lawyers I think one of the lawyers
working for Trump's legal team Alan
Dershowitz maybe better than anyone shot
down the Democrats impeachment case in
about three minutes and Alan Dershowitz
who has been on
my show and he's been on other shows
that I've guest hosted you know I mean
he goes on the media a whole lot I think
part of part of the reason why he was so
able to articulate this case is one
because he's very media savvy and two
because he's actually been the professor
for many of the senators who were in
that chamber you know he's a very
well-known harvard law professor he's
got a relationship with these senators
including senator Ted Cruz who's hosting
the podcast that I'm co-hosting verdict
he gets up there and in three four
minutes shoots down the whole thing
first he shot down this idea that John
Bolton's book leak is a bombshell you
know yesterday we heard that the former
national security adviser for Trump John
Bolton in his book accused Trump of
engaging in a quid pro quo this is
thrown impeachment into chaos Alan
Dershowitz gets up there and makes the
point no one else had made which is not
to dispute the alleged claims in John
Bolton's book but actually just to get
up there and say hey even if everything
john bolton said is true it still is not
an impeachable offense demonstrate the
dangers of employing the vague
subjective and politically malleable
phrase abuse of power as a
constitutionally permissible criteria
for the removal of a president now it
follows it follows from this that if a
president any president were to have
done what The Times reported about the
contact of the Bolton manuscript that
would not constitute an impeachable
offense
let me repeat nothing in the Bolton
revelations even if true would rise to
the level of an abuse of power or an
impeachable offense that is clear from
the history that is clear from the
language of the Constitution you cannot
turn conduct that is not impeachable
into impeachable conduct simply by using
words like quid pro quo and personal
benefit thank you thank you for saying
that
the reason that this leak came out right
now right before the Republican senators
are gonna vote on whether or not to
require more witnesses to testify an
impeachment potentially dragging this
whole impeachment farce out for weeks
and weeks rather than letting it just
die on Friday or Saturday the reason it
happened now is because the Democrats
failed they failed to get Trump they
failed to get Trump on Russia they
failed to get Trump on his taxes they
failed to get Trump on stormy Daniels
they try they fail to get Trump on
Ukraine though they had a whole house
investigation of Ukraine they had three
potential impeachment articles vague
abuse of power vague obstruction of
Congress and bribery they had one actual
crime they were accusing him of they
dropped that article because they knew
they didn't have him so now they're just
trying to grasp but any straw they can
and wait for the most convenient moment
to set these leaks to try to pretend
like it's a big deal what Alan
Dershowitz says is not a big deal even
if this is true and we don't know if
it's true but even if it is still not an
impeachable offense then what professor
Dershowitz does very well is just
dismantle the whole argument because he
showed that if we adopt the houses new
standard for impeachment which is
basically if House Democrats don't like
the cut of your jib you're gone how that
would have caused many many American
presidents to be impeached all the way
back to George Washington we'll get to
that in a second first I got to thank
our friends at Rock Auto you know I said
that I I really wished I had heard of
some of my sponsors back when my car
just broke down months ago Rock Auto is
one of them that could have saved me a
whole lot of money and fortunately can
save me a lot of money right now
rockauto.com is a family business that
has been serving Auto Parts customers
online for 20 years which means they've
been serving Auto Parts customers online
pretty much since there's been an online
okay you can go to rockauto.com you can
shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers and they've
got everything they've got engine
control modules brake parts to tail
lamps
Royall even new carpet it for everything
whether it's your classic car it's your
daily Drive you can get all of it in a
few easy clicks now what I love about it
is when I go to it to an actual like
brick-and-mortar auto parts store they
never have my part what they do is they
go online they probably go to
rockauto.com and then they get it in and
then they charge me a whole lot of money
but when I go to rockauto.com
even I I don't know anything about cars
I can easily navigate I can find exactly
the parts that I need and then you can
do that too so right now head over to
Rock Auto comm include the word Knowles
canna wles in there how did you hear
about us box so that they know we sent
you you will always get reliably low
prices these are great guys family
business to work with and so easy to
navigate rockauto.com
right in Knowles canna wles and there
how did you hear about us box so very
important that professor Dershowitz
knocks down the John Bolton argument
especially because senators like Mitt
Romney Susan Collins the squishier
Republican senators they've been using
the Bolton bombshell as an excuse to try
to drag out impeachment and Dershowitz
says there's really no reason to do that
other than you don't like the president
then he knocks down the houses entire
argument their entire new standard for
impeachment by showing the chaos that it
would have wrought in American politics
all the way back to George Washington I
will now give you a list of presidents
who in our history have been accused of
abusing their power who would be subject
to impeachment under the house managers
view of the Constitution George
Washington refusal to turn over
documents related to the Jay Treaty John
Adams signing and enforcing the alienist
Sedition laws Thomas Jefferson
purchasing Louisiana without
congressional authorization I'll go on
John Quincy Adams Martin Van Bernd John
Tyler arbitrary despotic and corrupt use
of the veto power James Polk here I
quote Abraham Lincoln Abraham Lincoln
accused Polk of abusing his power of his
office contemptuously disregarding the
Constitution usurping the role of
I wasn't assuming the role of dictator
he didn't seek to impeach him just
sought to defeat him Abraham Lincoln
Abraham Lincoln was accused of abusing
his power for suspending the writ of
habeas corpus during the Civil War
President Grant Grover Cleveland William
McKinley Theodore Roosevelt William Taft
Woodrow Wilson Franklin Roosevelt Harry
Truman Jimmy Carter Ronald Reagan quote
concerning iran-contra he goes on he
goes on there more presidents even after
that they would all have been subject to
impeachment if we adopted this new
fantasy of the constitutional
requirement that the House Democrats are
coming up with now I've been saying this
since the very beginning of impeachment
you know there were some conservatives
out there who say that we don't use
impeachment enough that actually the
House of Representatives should impeach
more presidents they should take more
power back into the house I don't want
that I think that's a terrible idea I
don't think that we need to give more
power to the legislature I think we've
given a lot of power to the legislature
and frankly the legislature has given a
lot of that power away we cannot we
should not get into a situation where
the president is serving at the pleasure
of the House of Representatives some of
the greatest presidents permit perhaps
all of the greatest presidents in
American history would have been thrown
out of office because of that we must
have order in this country you know the
argument that some conservatives make
for using impeachment more is that it
gives us more Liberty the House of
Representatives is more accountable to
the American people because they're
elected every two years they're they
know their districts and so therefore we
should give more power to them that's
not a real kind of Liberty you know the
only way that we can enjoy the blessings
of liberty as we call them is if we have
a stable government you don't get to
enjoy blessings of liberty if you don't
have a stable government and if you get
into a situation where we're just
impeaching every president the minute
that a different party gets into the
House of Representatives if you get in
there to that situation you are not
going to have any kind of stability
whatsoever now speaking of the
presidency and we have a lot of 20/20
news to get to but
first while the pro-abortion activists
are shouting their abortions on national
TV and referring to preborn babies as
parasites pro-lifers are fighting back
all of us here at the Daily wire have
spoken out for life last year ben
shapiro addressed a crowd of a hundred
thousand at the March for Life in
Washington DC our advertisers as a
result of those actions were targeted by
left-wing fake media watchdogs and
operatives and we lost a lot of revenue
from that this is a constant battle to
protect pro-life advocacy from the
forces of abortion another group that
has experienced this is a live-action
live-action is one of the most important
voices in the pro-life movement they've
helped to expose Planned Parenthood and
other abortion clinics for the horrific
crimes they commit pro bortion activists
have targeted live action and censured
them on social media platforms when they
don't succeed in kicking them off
altogether that's why our daily wire
members are so important your membership
helps keep our cameras on it keeps our
microphones turned up even when the left
is pressuring our sponsors you can keep
the pro-life message from being
cancelled from now until January 31st a
portion of any daily wire.com membership
will be donated to live action with the
promo code live action so head on over
to daily wire.com sign up and make your
voice heard head over to daily wire.com
we'll be right back with a lot more
all right 20/20 news Elizabeth Warren is
probably coming to the end of the line
here poor old liya Wafaa just not gonna
make it over the finish line if the
polls are to be believed and I think Liz
Warren knows that too she knows her
campaign is in serious trouble she's way
down in Iowa she's way down in New
Hampshire if she pulls an upset then
she's back in the race but if she really
gets clobbered in both those states it's
hard to see how she comes back
especially in New Hampshire which is
right in her backyard right near
Massachusetts so this could be the end
Liz Warren is throwing a Hail Mary here
she's pretending that she has already
won the nomination and she is launching
an ad directly against Donald Trump he
grew up in a mansion in New York City
she grew up here in Oklahoma he got
millions from his dad's real estate
empire her dad ended up a janitor he
scammed students at his for-profit
school she got debts forgiven for
students who were scammed when someone
shows you who they are believe them
Trump's life taught him how to get rich
on the backs of others Elizabeth Warren
will be a president who works for you
I'm Elizabeth Warren and I approve this
message so this would be a desperate
play regardless of how the actual
content of the ad turned out but how
tone-deaf to make the thesis of the ad
when someone shows you who they are
believe them okay well is Elizabeth
Warren a Cherokee who submits recipes
for powwow chow oh no she's a liar and a
fraud and the whitest woman in America
who pretended to be a minority for
decades to advance her own career at the
expense of minorities is that when
Elizabeth Warren tells you that her kid
goes to public school don't believe her
because she's lying to you when
Elizabeth Warren tells you she was fired
for being pregnant as a teacher don't
believe her because she lied about that
too and she lies about just about
everything it's a really pathetic ad
campaigns do this when they get to the
end of the line when they need to throw
a Hail Mary so what they'll do is
pretend to be very confident you know
you'll see candidates start running ads
against the general election opponent
you'll see them talking about their
cabinet that they're gonna fill or their
running mate or that and that you do it
because you need something you need any
momentum to try to stave off what is
usually the inevitable and it would seem
to be the inevitable for Elizabeth
Warren nobody is happier about that than
Hillary Clinton who I think would
probably have to go get Liz Warren
Epstein if Warren became the first
female president instead of Hillary so
Hillary Clinton is making the rounds
right now she's promoting a documentary
about herself her favorite subject and
she is attacking Bernie Sanders she's
saying you know she's trying to downplay
the attacks on Bernie a little bit but
she's still getting them in there and in
interviews she's saying initially she
said nobody likes Bernie Sanders and
he's never accomplished anything in his
life now she's just saying I think it's
important to look at somebody's record
and look at what they've gotten done and
see whether you agree with them or not
and then of course the question comes to
her is she going to run for office and
she cannot possibly quell her urge to be
President I know you're not running but
do you ever feel the urge that like I
could beat him if I were or like I wish
I go yeah I certainly feel the urge
because I feel like the 2016 election
was really an odd an odd time and
outcome and the more we learned the more
that seems to be the case but I'm going
to support the people who are running
now and do everything I can to help
elect the Democratic nominee classic
Hillary she's implying here not so
subtly that the 2016 election was rigged
and illegitimate that's what she means
by odd and she says the more we learn
them the odd or it seems which is just
not true initially they said that Trump
conspired with Russia to steal the
election and that was completely
disproven by a two and a half year 32
million-dollar investigation that you
and I all paid for anyway I digress the
reason that Hillary is able to get these
kind of hints in she's able to talk
about how she really wants to run for
president now the reason that reporters
are even asking her about it is because
the Democratic field is so weak because
they don't really have
anybody Elizabeth Warren who was once
considered a bright star in this field
is really fading she's fading in the
polls she's fading in the minds of the
elites who were promoting her on
television and elsewhere so she's
throwing the Hail Mary's Pete Budaj edge
he's also dropping in the polls he's not
doing very well
we spoke yesterday about how he's really
not ready for primetime now it's coming
down to Bernie and Biden and and Biden
the House Democrats pretty much threw
him under the bus the other day during
the impeachment trial it's cuz Biden
just doesn't have what it takes Biden's
eyeball is exploding and his teeth are
falling out on the debate stage doesn't
really set you up and that's that's
before you even look at his record which
is pretty unimpressive he's run for
president twice lost both times one time
had to drop out for being a plagiarist
and a liar
so that leaves Bernie Sanders who
honeymooned in the Soviet Union nearly
80 years old videos of him singing
communist folk songs with the Russkies
shirtless swilling vodka in the soviet
union so they're really in a terrible
spot and Hillary Clinton is a fairly
attractive candidate in this spot now
we're all hoping that she runs because
it would be so so incredibly funny to
beat her again but unfortunately I think
she knows the bed ship has sailed
as well onto the culture beyond the
politics onto the culture and maybe back
into the politics then drag queens story
hour is coming to a public school near
you those of us who pay attention to the
culture predicted this we told you it
would happen we were told that we were
being hysterical that what a ridiculous
argument it's just it a couple libraries
it's not going to schools it's going to
schools the left wingers and the squishy
right wingers initially said this is no
big deal some people even said that drag
queen story hour which is this
phenomenon of drag queens twerking for
little toddlers at libraries they called
it a blessing of Liberty I don't know
what kind of blessing that would be but
that's what they said more tradition
minded conservatives knew that was BS
that is never how the culture war works
it never stays contained it always
spread
the leftist culture war always starts
from a position of individual rights and
privacy so what what they usually begin
with is they say hey what people do
behind closed doors that's none of your
business
okay what people do in their own
bedrooms that's none of your business
then the private quickly becomes the
public all of a sudden it's hey what
people do in their local library that's
none of your business
hey what people do in all the libraries
in San Francisco that's none of your
business
hey well people do in states all around
the country that's none of your business
pretty soon it's the whole culture the
private becomes public you know the left
told us this in the 1960s one of the
slogans of the feminists in particular
but many of the left wing radicals in
the 60s was the personal is the
political which means that the private
is the public what is private and
personal to me is actually a political
statement and that is where politics can
be fought because that will affect what
we do in public so that's what happened
with with so-called gay rights right it
turned quickly from an acceptance into
tolerance of homosexuality which was the
argument the 90s and the 2000s into
fundamentally redefining marriage and if
you don't accept this radical
redefinition of marriage you're a bigot
you could lose your job you could be
excluded from public life happened with
transgender ideology initially it was
hey be nice to people
be nice to men who wear dresses I don't
think anyone disagreed with that all of
a sudden it became abolishing same-sex
bathrooms abolishing the girls locker
room little girls have to change next to
grown men now very quickly same thing is
happening with drag queens story our
same exact formula the left proposes a
radical change
conservatives point to the slippery
slope than the left mocks us for talking
about the slippery slope and before you
know it not five minutes later we are
way way down that slippery slope were
exactly where we said that we would be
drag queens story our starts in San
Francisco in 2015 starts because a queer
author self-described I'm not using any
sort of epithets Michele T organized the
first drag queen story hour in San
Francisco now drag queen story hour on
its website boasts of 45
dependently operated chapters across the
u.s. New York Washington Chicago many
other cities now it's leaving the
libraries and it's entering schools it's
entering schools all the way up to 12th
grade and all the way back to pre-k
earlier than kindergarten one teacher
who's had drag queens story hour in his
school said quote drag queens story hour
gave my first Raider is a fun and
interactive platform to talk and think
about social and emotional issues like
acceptance being yourself and loving who
you are right not necessarily a bad
thing he goes on during our debrief
students were preaching the incredible
lessons they had learned like it's okay
to be different
okay depends on what we mean by
different it's not okay to be evil it's
not okay to like punch your classmate I
guess that'd be different but it's okay
to certainly be a different color be a
different sex be a different personality
sure okay and the teacher goes on there
is no such thing as boy and girl things
no such thing it now that's a little bit
different there's no so what do you mean
there's no such you're saying there's no
such thing as boys and girls then if
there's no such thing as things that
pertain to boys and girls then there's
no such thing as boys and girls that's
some pretty radical stuff it's both
untrue and also psychologically
potentially very very damaging to kids
who are three and four years old and
that is the agenda of drag queens story
hour as I and many others have been
telling you for months now as the left
and the squishy conservatives were
mocking us beyond the drag queen story
our here's a lesson a lesson plan from a
public school in Brooklyn just reported
in the New York Post this is from pre-k
preschool at PS 58 quote everybody has
the right to choose their own gender by
listening to their own heart and mind
everyone gets to choose if they are a
boy or a girl or both or neither or
something else
that's from a lesson plan at a public
school in Brooklyn now the usual
conservative response here is not enough
because the here's the usual cancer
response at least in the kind of
libertarian conservative culture we live
in the left pushes a radical agenda and
then conservatives rather than pushing
back retreat into their own private
spheres so for instance the left pushes
this radical agenda into the public
schools and what do conservatives do do
they Duke it out on the field of the
public school no they retreat into
private school where they retreat into
home school the private school and home
school movement great thing all for it
but you also have to fight the actual
battle that's being waged which is in
the public schools if you don't then the
left simply dominates the culture often
conservatives are fond of saying
politics of doubt is downstream of
culture which is true however politics
also affects culture politics has a big
effect on our culture look at even how
economic policies can affect culture we
see that we saw this in the Soviet Union
we see this after Ronald Reagan
liberalized the the economic policies in
the United States we had flourishing we
had thriving sawdust in the Great
Society in the economic policies in the
1960s and 70s wrought crazy effects all
over the culture it is not enough to say
hey conservatives can just private
school they can just go to home school
do you know how many students are
home-schooled in America 1.6 million
that's cool I mean good for them glad I
hope hopefully they're getting a good
education glad that people have more
control over their own kids education
only 1.6 million you know me kids go to
private school 5.8 million it's good
it's more obviously more than go go to a
home school still 5.8 million do you
know how many students go to public
school in the United States more than 50
million 1.6 5.8 50 million so if
conservatives if all we do is retreat
into our own little culture and to our
own little institutions and cede all the
big institutions to the left the
then that that will be the fastest way
to lose the culture and it's been our
strategy for at least 50 60 years now
and it hasn't worked out well and the
left's argument is BS anyway here's how
you can fight the argument the pro drag
queen story our type people say that we
need to let drag queen story our into
public schools because that's just
neutral you know that's just exposing
students to new ideas and we want
students to be exposed to all sorts of
ideas we don't teach them what to think
we teach them how to think which is a
completely meaningless statement and BS
you cannot teach someone without
teaching them what to think you cannot
teach history without teaching people
what to think about history you can
present different arguments but
ultimately one of those arguments is
going to be more persuasive than the
other
you can't teach people mathematics
without teaching them what to think
about mathematics
you can't teach people language without
teaching them what to think about
language ok they start from that premise
it's just neutral just let that idea in
okay well what do you think they would
say if you suggested teaching the Bible
in schools or if you suggested opening
school each day with a prayer as we did
throughout the United States until about
60 years ago do you think they would say
oh of course well yeah because we have
this neutral ground and absolutely we
want all these ideas we don't want to
limit any buddies exposure to ideas I
mean especially the Bible which is the
single most important book ever written
and without which you can't understand
anything else in our culture do you
think do you think they would say that I
don't think they would say that I think
they would do as they've done for 50 60
years
and get both of those things straight
out of the public schools their argument
is disingenuous the key here is that
liberalism is not neutral we need to
fight back and stop ceding these
institutions and arguments to the left
the left does not have your best
interests at heart
they might prattle on about how much
they love humanity but they don't seem
to care very much for actual humans and
you and your children are the actual
humans who could be harmed by this
leftist culture if we don't fight back
we're just gonna find ourselves further
and further and further down that
slippery slope hope I don't have to see
you there that's our show we got a lot
more to get to
but you know we'll get to it tomorrow
we'll also get to it later on tonight on
the number one podcast in America
verdict with Ted Cruz which I have the
wonderful opportunity to co-host so
we'll see you there or we'll see you
back here tomorrow
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Noel's show the Michael Nolt show is
produced by Ben Davies director Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Sterling technical producer Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski
editor and associate producer danny
D'Amico audio mixer robin Fenderson hair
and makeup Jessa alvera production
assistants McKenna Waters and Ryan love
the Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 if
you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and he can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there